buonasera allora prima di tutto le scuse
perché se sono su questo video
ovviamente perché non sono lì
fisicamente del che mi dispiaccio molto
questioni di salute neanche minima di
mio figlio di due anni e mezzo ma sto
annoiarvi vi dico solo più o meno
all'ora in cui dovevo prendere un treno
per essere liero al pronto soccorso
comunque adesso se vi sto mandando
registrando questo video è perché mio
figlio dorme finalmente dopo tanto
finalmente la febbre scesa sotto i 39
sono più sereno ma appunto mi rode
parecchio un po perché lecce ci vengono
in questo momento della mia vita
praticamente tutte le strade portano a
lecce continuamente e quindi ci tornavo
per tante ragioni ma soprattutto questa
mi mi allettava mi piaceva l'idea di
parlare in quel contesto su questi
argomenti quando mi hanno raccontato che
il tema della di questa edizione nuova
memoria che quindi avrei dovuto parlare
in qualche modo di musica e memoria ho
detto beh non faccio altro da tutta la
vita che mettere insieme queste due cose
dal mio punto di vista è probabilmente
avrei iniziato anche un po per rompere
il ghiaccio
partendo dall'aspetto più letterale o
anche un proprio stupido della questione
quello che un e monica ricordare per
esempio testi parole metri che per uno
che scrive testi spesso parecchia lunghi
è un tema che mi sta a cuore quindi di
avere raccontato dei trucchi che ho
imparato delle tecniche ma anche lì
magari qualche aneddoto gli episodi le
volte più imbarazzanti in cui in questi
sono stati i vuoti di memoria come
minimo bossi diciamo così o forse avrei
fatto un esempio ricorrendo a una
canzonetta di di un po di tempo fa che
si chiamava stizzisce tesi che realtà
era solo un insieme di scioglilingua ne
aggiunge lo facevo solo dal vivo
aggiungevo ogni sera anch'esso di lingua
locale a secondo video di trovarsi era
un puro esercizio di stile un percorso
su un filo insomma però divertente in
genere veniva forse avremmo andato una
base l'avrei fatto sopra avrei preso una
chitarra per fargli capire di che si
trattava niente di molto serio ed
edificante una cosa tipo sopra la panca
la capra campa sotto vantata tra creta
sopra va cambiata la capra e stanca da
mancato la collega sopra manca insomma
cosa di questo livello lo saprei anti
fatto la parte in cui faccio se
l'arcivescovo di costantinopoli series
arcivescovo discostanti che normalizza
seri disagi vescovi scostanti notori 0
estivo e come si risarcire sgavisc
costantino valorizzerebbero stizzisce
schizzi si mostri sicily evento insomma
cosa del genere non lo so eppure quali
ha insomma qualcosa si inventavano però
sì questa è la memoria dei testi poi c'è
la memoria della musica degli accordi ma
semmai l'aspetto che mi interessava di
minare quello legato più al mio mestiere
invece gabay pala parlato più volentieri
di suono di esperienza sonora che è un
argomento che mi sta molto a cuore sono
abbastanza malato del suono intorno a me
del mondo cerco il suono anche dove non
c'è una volta mi sono ritrovato a
suonare a contare il suono dei quali
insomma vi avrei spostato su quello
d'altronde ho dato un titolo che erano
moria del suono
il sogno della memoria a noia del suono
insomma quei titoli un po da convegno ma
dentro ci stava molta sostanza secondo
me forse va raccontato di un esperimento
scientifico ad esempio perché per farla
breve dimostra come noi ricordiamo molto
meno bene i suoni rispetto alle immagini
informazioni anche tattili per non
parlare degli odori che quasi per
antonomasia un profumo è una cosa che ci
ricorda qualcosa di preciso per un sacco
di tempo per anche cose lontanissime nel
tempo le associamo immagine profumo
molto di meglio di come associamo
immagine e suono avremmo cercato di
capire perché vi avrei detto che altri
studi però dimostrano anche questo è
forse ancora più importante nel formarci
nel diventare memoria ma in un altro
modo
non abbiamo tanto capito gli avrei detto
che forse la psicanalisi ha capito
meglio di altre essenze quanto è
importante il suono quando nella pancia
la voce di nostra madre
da informazioni a un io che non è
neanche ancora unico vero ma è un neo
pelle come qualcuno lo chiama sole
emozioni quasi sensazioni e quella
cadenza quel modo di parlare disegna
nostra vita determina come altri suoni
che già dalla pancia sentiamo determina
nel nostro umore molto più di tante
altre informazioni che ci arrivano alla
musica in che modo cambia l'umore perché
centro la memoria ricordiamo delle cose
era bello parlare di questo e mi
dispiace non poterlo fare anche perché
gli esempi sarebbero stati tanti poi
avrei creato e crea chiesto di spostare
l'argomento un po più solo appunto il
suono della memoria se sono che per
ognuno di noi è la nostra memoria la
nostra storia di avrei invitato a
pensare al mondo in questi termini
avremmo fatto degli esempi forse validi
per tutti di cui grandi suoni che non
possono non essere scolpiti invece nella
nostra memoria
magari per degli eventi drammatici o
gioiosi aver parlato di quelli che
possono venire a mente a me dalla dalla
sirena dei bombardamenti di mia nonna
sotto sotto appunto durante la seconda
guerra mondiale non so fino ai suoni dei
nostri cellulari che ci dicono le
informazioni che in realtà codifichiamo
abbiamo memorizzato sappiamo distinguere
un team che ci dicesse un messaggio una
notifica quindi li è memoria in qualche
modo del suono molto codificata però
sono estranee onde abbiamo parlato anche
di terremoti perché ci sono appena state
e quel suono scolpisce qualcosa anche
quello nelle nostre coscienze e magari
non tanto il boato sottostante che forse
più una vibrazione che un suono ma se
qualcuno per esempio avesse visto come
me in internet un po di filmati c'è quel
filmato dei cacciatori quella montagna
lì il suono che si sente e quello delle
foglie scossi con una violenza però che
nessuno ha mai sentito e quel suono che
in fondo è leggero in realtà più
drammatico dei tanti altri suoi insomma
gli avrei chiesto forse di pensare la
vostra storia attraverso i suoni di
farvi una vostra complessa e forse che
avrei fatto sentire la mia e l'avrei
fatta iniziare magari che non sono di
molle di un materasso quello su cui
saltavo da bambino e il suono del disco
che mettevano i miei genitori e che non
so perché mi piaceva tanto era un
pianoforte jazz di un certo errol garner
e probabilmente quasi sicuramente avrei
chiuso facendo di ascoltare una canzone
neanche se come ama scritto insieme
altri due amici capelloni un paio d'anni
fan siamo andati in giro per l'italia
per l'europa con delle canzoni che è uno
scritto insieme a posta la prima delle
quali era proprio una canzone che
parlava di suoni e di memoria iniziava
nicolò raccontando meravigliosamente
secondo me alcuni suoni della natura
della città quelli esterni quelli che
ascoltiamo tutti e poi proseguito io
parlando invece dei suoni che personali
quelli proprio della memoria è più o
meno questo è sentito questo il telefono
che squilla quando lo aspetti
le dita di mio padre sulla soli dette
non aver già amico tutti mezzogiorno la
serratura attori tu la campanella che
suona il tram quando riparte quella che
in un attimo tutta la classe il respiro
di un bambino oliate il silenzio della
né
io non riuscirò a stare lì posso provare
a registrare un bel filmato da inviare
per salutare ma zero stare lì io davanti
a le mans è una questione di coscienza
al sole mani
[Applauso]